they're normal distributions what we say
distribution all you mean is you've got
a bunch of scores temperatures highest
times and they are distributed across a
population we use the word normal
because this shape is the shape we see
everywhere in society in nature whenever
you're measuring things and this is the
phrase I'm going to give you whenever
you're measuring things that have some
random element so my sentence for
defining this is the normal distribution
is the pattern of data wherever and I
just want you to emphasize highlight
that word whenever it's astonishing that
this same pattern applies to everything
that you can observe and I'll tell you a
fun story about the same second question
the normal situation is a panel data
whenever you measure
a population set of scores with some
randomness so for example if we have a
look at our class and we measure the
heights of everyone right that's a
population that's a set of scores with
some randomness right like our heights
are all going to be have all of these
factors computed to them but it's not as
though we selected this group of people
to all be the toys to all be the
shortest or something like that so
there's some randomness that's been
added in and so our Heights are going to
look like this it's the same thing even
when we try not to do it randomly like
we have scores across our class for
exams and you see a pattern very similar
to this so I want to tell you this story
of how this came up and it's kind of
funny because mathematicians are sort of
read individuals so the fact that they
would do something like this is unusual
but one guy and I can't remember which
is either Spain or France so I'll have
to look this up later
ah he was convinced that his baker was
ripping him off who's convinced his back
was revealed he said yeah he's supposed
to be a one-kilogram life I've read that
supposed to give me just quite large but
he thought no you know what I think he's
constantly ripping me off by giving me a
loaf of bread that's labeled as a kilo
it's actually much lighter right so what
did he do he got a set of scores of the
weight of his loaf of bread and he just
did it many many times right now think
about this
loads of bread they're things with
randomness yeah they're not going to be
exactly the same every single time
specially if it's made by a human being
so you would expect
thing like this and sure enough period
when he found once you don't need to put
this in but what he found was the
average weight of all of his modes of
representation
right so he presented this and the bay
card was gotten in trouble for like you
know bad bad professional practice and
what have you got some fine etcetera so
he was happy so he's like great this is
fantastic
I've proven with this kind of little
statistical timing that this is not what
I was first be given but then what
happened was he thought okay I better I
better keep watching this guy because
just go he's got in trouble that doesn't
mean he's gonna fix things up right so
he continued to measure what kinds of
weights of bread that he got and he took
the mean right now the mean came up to a
kilogram so he's like oh well that's
good
but what he noticed was when he graph
them cuz if you're a mathematician of
course you're going to graph the size
with it right what he noticed was a
shape like this so we put like say Ikuo
right here okay he did notice there was
a hub over here rather than over 900
grams but he observed this shape in
snare
now we have language already to describe
what this is right this is not
symmetrical anymore it is negatively
skewed okay but here's the thing like
everywhere if you measure of heights if
you run races and measure times if you
measure temperatures and on and on if
there is something with an element of
randomness to it you must absolutely no
exceptions get this curve so he said
what on earth is going on
why is the curve changed and he realized
he was the one who made this complaint
it was a big public thing that he went
to court and so on and got this Baker in
trouble so the biggest solution was okay
no problem whenever I see this guy come
into the bakery I'm just gonna go have a
look through all of my loaves and give
him the heaviest one right so he didn't
change what he was doing his lows were
still all wider than there was supposed
to be right but he was taking away this
element of randomness who say actually
no what I'm going to deliberately see
deliberately pick all the heaviest ones
it ought to move the average so the
average will change but you lose this
actual shape that naturally comes up
whenever you measure a population and
this kind of they call this of forensic
statistics this is what people have to
do when they work out are so-and-so has
been cooking their books they haven't
been putting in declaring all of their
incomes of their taxes accurate or
they've been mucking around with their
financial figures so they can avoid this
tax or that tax they observe it by
things like this they look for patterns
that aren't what they're supposed to be
so you've got an idea of the picture let
me give you some language to formalize
the definition can you put two dot
points
[Music]
you would turn into fun okay let's uh
let's form items so the first thing you
noticed and I'm trying to use this story
to contrast is that it is a rough bell
curve right
it's a belter but importantly very very
importantly it is symmetrical it's not
kind of a bell curve we've a bit of a
skewed one way or the other it's a
proper bell curve with its center white
in the middle and no leaning one way or
the other now because of this property
it results in something really
interesting with our mean mode and
median what it means is the mean mode
and median this is unusual but it's the
thing with normal distributions we have
data the mean mode and the median should
all be equal when you have a look at the
curve it's somewhat obvious right
what is mean it's when you take the
average of everything or if you've got
high scores and low scores and they're a
match exactly symmetrical all the high
scores you've got will kind of balance
out with the license does that make
sense
just like when I gave you if I gave you
this set of scores
okay here's your mean you see 5.9 they
kind of just even each other out and
everything stays balanced right it's the
same with six and eight so the mean is
going to be smack bang in the middle
what's the mode I'll just let me just
the most frequent thing which on a graph
is the highest point right - great so
the highest point would be here which
again corresponds to the main because in
set companies
lastly set up the median can you see why
this line should be the median and not a
little bit off what is median maybe it's
the middle school and you can see the
exact same number of people on the left
as there are on the right so that means
we found the median and these three
should all be exactly alike